there is an enigmatic and Powerful
mathematical operation at work inside
everything from computer graphics and
neural networks to quantum physics
it's simple enough for high school
students to grasp yet so complex that
even seasoned mathematicians haven't
mastered it this operation is called
matrix multiplication matrix
multiplication is a very fundamental
operation in mathematics that appears in
many computations in engineering and in
physics a matrix is a two-dimensional
array of numbers on which you can
perform operations like addition and
multiplication
researchers have long sought more
efficient ways to multiply matrices
together so if you even just make it a
little bit faster larger problems come
into reach where for now we would say
that's too big to be a computable in a
reasonable time however actually finding
faster matrix multiplication methods is
a huge challenge but thanks to a new
tool researchers have finally broken a
long-standing matrix multiplication
record one that's more than 50 years old
what's their secret weapon
students of linear algebra are taught a
method for multiplying matrices based on
a centuries-old algorithm it goes like
this
multiply elements from the first row of
Matrix a and the First Column of Matrix
B and add them to get the first element
of Matrix C then repeat for the first
row of Matrix a and the second column of
Matrix B and add them for the second
element in Matrix C and so on
multiplying two two by two matrices this
way takes eight multiplication steps
multiplying any two n by n matrices with
the standard algorithm takes n cubed
steps which is why applying this method
to pairs of larger matrices quickly
becomes unwieldy if you take a matrix
that is twice as big then you have to
have a computation time that is eight
times more so you can imagine if you
double a couple of times then you take
eight times more a couple of times and
you will very soon reach the limits of
what a computer can do enter
volkerstraßen a German mathematician
known for his work analyzing algorithms
in 1969 he discovered a new algorithm to
multiply two by two matrices that
requires only seven multiplication steps
going from eight down to seven
multiplications may seem trivial and the
new addition steps look more complicated
but strawson's algorithm offers dramatic
computational savings for larger
matrices that's because when multiplying
large matrices they can be broken down
into smaller ones for example an 8x8
Matrix can reduce to a series of nested
two by two matrices so straws and
savings applied to these smaller Matrix
multiplications propagate over and over
applying strassins to an 8x8 Matrix
results in a third fewer multiplication
steps compared to the standard algorithm
for very large matrices these savings
vastly outweigh the computation costs of
the extra additions
a year after strassen invented his
algorithm IBM researcher shmuel Winograd
proved it was impossible to use six or
fewer multiplications to multiply two by
two matrices thus also proving that
strassen's with its seven
multiplications is the best solution for
half a century the most efficient method
known for multiplying two matrices of
any reasonable size was to break them
down and apply strassen's algorithm that
was until October 2022 a new algorithm
was revealed that beat strasons
specifically for multiplying two 4x4
matrices where the elements are only
zero or one this new algorithm made it
possible to multiply large matrices even
faster by breaking them into four by
four matrices instead of two by twos so
who or what was behind this breakthrough
this new algorithm was discovered by
Google's artificial intelligence
research lab deepmind for more than a
decade deepmind has gone garnered
attention for training AI systems to
master a host of games everything from
Atari Pong to chess
then in 2016 deepminds alphago achieved
what was considered impossible at the
time it defeated the top ranked human go
player Lee sedol in a best of five match
this Victory shattered The Limited
notion of what's possible for computers
to achieve
deepmind then set its sights on a
problem even more challenging than go I
was like very surprised that even for
the very small cases we don't even know
what's the optimal way of doing uh
matrix multiplication and at some point
we realized that this is actually a very
good fit for machine learning techniques
to tackle matrix multiplication deepmind
started with an algorithm descended from
alphago called Alpha tensor Alpha tensor
is built on a reinforcement learning
algorithm called Alpha zero so what one
needs to do is to go really beyond
the alpha zero reinforcement learning
algorithm to and to tackle this huge
search space and to develop techniques
to find this these needles in a very
very large Haystack Alpha tensor isn't
the first computer program to assist
with mathematical Research In 1976 two
mathematicians proved what's called The
Four Color theorem using a computer the
theorem States you only need four colors
to fill in any map so no neighboring
regions match the pair verified their
proof by processing all
1936 required cases requiring more than
1 000 hours of computing time back then
the larger mathematical Community was
not prepared to see the logical
reasoning to a machine however the field
has since come a long way Alpha tensor
was trained with a technique called
reinforcement learning which is kind of
like playing a game reinforcement
learning strategically penalizes and
rewards an AI system as it experiments
with different ways to achieve its given
task driving the program towards an
optimal solution but what kind of game
should Alpha tensor play in search of
more efficient matrix multiplication
algorithms this is where the term tensor
and Alpha tensor comes into play a
tensor is just an array of numbers with
any number of Dimensions vectors are one
detensors and matrices are 2D tensors
the process of multiplying any two
matrices of a given size can be
described by a single unique 3D tensor
for example when multiplying any two two
by two matrices we can build the
corresponding 3D tensor each dimension
of this Cube represents one of the
matrices each element in the cube can be
1 0 or negative one
the matrix product C is created by
combining elements from matrices A and B
like this
and so on
until you have the full matrix
multiplication tensor
[Music]
now you can use a process called tensor
decomposition to break down this 3D
tensor into building blocks similar to
taking apart a cube puzzle one natural
way to break tensors down is into what's
called rank 1 tensors which are just
products of vectors the trick is each
rank 1 tensor here describes a
multiplication step in a matrix
multiplication algorithm for example
this rank 1 tensor represents the first
multiplication step in the standard
algorithm A1 times B1 the next rank 1
tensor represents A2 times B3 adding
these two rank 1 tensors yields the
first element in the product C1 here are
the next two rank 1 tensors representing
the multiplications A1 times B2 and A2
times B4 which form C2 eventually the
entire standard algorithm with its eight
multiplication steps is represented by
decomposing the 3D tensor into eight
rank 1 tensors these all add back up
into the original 3D tensor but it's
possible to decompose a 3D tensor in
different ways strassen's seven
multiplication steps for the same 2x2
matrix multiplication looks like this
these rank 1 tensors are more complex
and this is still a full decomposition
but in fewer steps which add back up to
the original tensor so the fewer rank 1
tensors you use to fully decompose a 3D
tensor the fewer multiplication steps
used in the tensor's corresponding
matrix multiplication
deepmind's construction of a single
player game for Alpha tensor to play and
learn from was key find an algorithm for
this matrix multiplication that requires
the fewest multiplication steps possible
is a vague request but it becomes a
clearly defined computer task once it's
formulated as decompose this 3D tensor
using as few unique rank 1 tensors as
possible it's really hard to describe
what does what the search space looks
like in the particular case of matrix
multiplication that's that's quite it's
quite convenient to formulate it in that
space because then we can deploy our
search techniques and our machine
learning techniques in order to to
search in that very very large but
formalizable storage spaces Alpha
tensor's play was simple it was
programmed to guess rank 1 tensors to
subtract from the original 3D tensor to
decompose it down to zero the fewer rank
1 tensors it used the more rewards it
got each rank one tensor that you remove
from from the the 3D tensor is is has a
cost has a cost of let's say one and so
we want to figure out what's the way of
achieving the goal with the fewest uh
penalties and so that's what the system
is trying to learn how to do it's
learning to estimate well when I'm in
this kind of configuration roughly how
many penalties do I think I'm going to
incur before I get to the goal but
tensor decomposition is not an easy game
to master for even a three by three
matrix multiplication with only elements
0 or 1. the number of possible tensor
decompositions exceeds the number of
atoms in the universe still over the
course of its training Alpha tensor
started to home in on patterns to
decompose the tensor efficiently within
minutes it rediscovered strassen's
algorithm then the program went even
further it beats Dawson's algorithm for
multiplying two 4x4 matrices in modulo 2
where the elements are only zero or one
breaking the 50-year record instead of
the standard algorithms 64
multiplication steps or strason's 49
Alpha tensor's algorithm used only 47
multiplications Alpha tensor also
discovered thousands of other new Fast
algorithms including ones for 5x5
matrices in modulo 2.
so will programs like Alpha tensor
turning away in server rooms pulling out
new mathematical discoveries from lines
of code make mathematicians obsolete
ultimately I think this will not replace
uh like the
mathematicians or or anything like that
this I think provides a good tool that
can help mathematicians find new results
and guide their intuition that's exactly
what happened just days after the alpha
tensor results were first published in
the journal Nature
two mathematicians in Austria Manuel
cowers and Jacob musbauer used Alpha
tensor's 96 step 5x5 matrix
multiplication algorithm as inspiration
to push even further and then Jacob
suggested we just take the algorithm
that the iPhone found
as a starting point and see whether
there is something in the neighborhood
of this and we could have an additional
drop
and indeed that that was the case so it
was a very short computation for uh for
our new mechanism that was able to
reduce the 96 to 95. and this video and
published in India Cafe
the right way to look at this is as a
fantastic example of a collaboration
between a particular kind of technology
and mathematicians the true potential
for human and artificial intelligence
collaboration is a frontier that is only
now being fully explored I don't think
that people could be made
irrelevant by by any of this kind of
work I think it just empowers people to
do more
foreign
[Music]